and the fisa vaccine has been approved
for five to 11 year olds
by the healthcare products regulatory
body the mhra
the jab has already been approved for
that age group in countries including
the united states ashley hernandez has
more on this broken story
when it comes to assessing uh
vaccinations and who should be given
what vaccine there are two bodies
involved in that decision the mhra the
uk's medical regulator who decides if
this product if this vaccine is fit for
use and how it's made but there is also
the involvement of the jcvi the joint
committee on immunization and
vaccination that is the body that
decides and advises the government who
should get it whether it's worth any
certain age group even being offered the
vaccine and then going on to receive it
so what the government advisors sitting
on the jcvi have decided they have said
that
they've decided against recommending the
use of the fisa vaccine for those aged
between five and eleven however those
who are
in that
immunosuppressed clinically vulnerable
group in that category they will be
offered it they will get the an adapted
pfizer vaccine that is the one that's
been approved by the uk's medical
regulator and what we're seeing on our
screens now is a quote from dr june rain
the chief executive of the medical
regulator she has said a detailed review
of all side effects reports to date has
found that the overwhelming majority
relate to mild symptoms such as a sore
arm or flu like illness now that relates
to what the mhra have said they have
said in their view
um the vaccine has been approved this
particular adapted vaccine has been
approved for this age group between five
to 11 year olds however
the jcvi the joint committee on
immunization and vaccination and those
as i say are the government advisors who
will then go on to
advise the government and then it's it's
more than likely that they will take on
that advice they have said that healthy
five to 11 year olds should hold off
from having this vaccination they say at
the moment those in a clinical
clinically vulnerable group or those who
live with someone who's immunosuppressed
should be offered this vaccination but
as i say the mhra say in time it would
be the case that all five to 11 year
olds may well have it but the jcvi say
at the moment all healthy five to 11
year olds should hold up from having it
it will only be offered to those who fit
that specific category they say they
will need more evidence before offering
out more widely